hey guys is Dennis hear the fan of fake
hero and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of the first two episodes
of one of my favorite shows justify its
back coloso time yeah it's like murder
of crows and the kids are alright cuz
they're not all right yeah not all right
yeah so the premiere in the second
episode yeah I like the direction of
where it's going because I felt lot even
the last season was good yeah I didn't
really like the overall story like it
didn't really interest me the whole
thing with writer shoot in the who's
this guy and dying so and so like just
might still great show great not a lot
of great characters but I felt like it
was a little yeah yeah this show it and
I really got to actually like right
after i saw that premiere like this show
i can already tell me like this is gonna
be better than last season like it just
it's much more focused yes I mean just
likes to start everything off we have
Raylan going to Florida to talk to the
the crows his his cousin's you know yeah
Julie's doing cousins yeah Michael
Rapaport it right it is playing like
obviously probably gonna be one of the
villains right of this season these are
the Florida curls which are even crazier
in the cruiser and Kentucky so we have
that side it's been then we have I
always forget you no longer know the guy
that they killed the one that that
killed uh the Cuban guys looking I the
cuban guy they got other guy with the
coast poker game the cousin right now
you the curl yeah yeah that was
lieutenant uh Randy Disher from monk I
don't know if you ever watched a monk
never saw a monk but he was like this
goofy guy so is funny seeing him play
this dislike goofy in a different way
like this total like white trash like
you just photos is a great job casting
that's one thing we've always done while
was casting and you know of course and
we go to Detroit and see walton goggins
I can't think of the active look at that
character's name Emily Crowder Boyd
Crowder and see them in Detroit trying
to work out a crazy scene in Detroit
that was intense you know trying to
figure out why the shipments are coming
down to Kentucky with what's going on
with that so I love it how both it's
almost like you have two guys in
different areas two of our favorite
characters you know
wang Goggins and you have you know
Raylan down there in Florida just trying
to like you know see what's going on the
different mysteries to uncover railing
with the crows and the drug problem in
Detroit was a great way to start off the
season yeah it's funny because of how
dude crow got 300,000 dollars from the
government because of Raylan so now he's
rich and of course you know this is kind
of what they say about like people who
win the lottery like a lot of times they
just keep doing do what they do and
eventually become bankrupt and Dewey's
kind of like Oh instead of like saving
his money is like I'm just gonna buy
this you know I'm gonna be the brothel
and what else would you do a three
hundred thousand dollars it is so stupid
I mean like the whole courtroom see when
the when the judge is like the courts
going to give me 300 you know he's like
three hundred dollars it's like you're
in a thousand you idiot you think he's
it's it's just so like all the
characters are great on that yeah and
then Raylan goes to see him I love the
part where he does decides not to like
punch him right or hurt him he shoots
the pool the portable pool yeah it's a I
mean it's just such a great show it's
getting like you've said this several
times about how this show watch is
almost better in big chunks and there
was only you can talk about each episode
that sounds like all this so much happen
but like over time they do a great sub
developing story throughout you know
each episode one at a time and yeah this
is a focus in this season seemed spot-on
right and we have to mention that they
they have announced there will be a
season six but it will be the final
season right next season is gonna be the
final season i like that i mean we heard
that the news with Boardwalk Empire I
mean five six seasons that's great i
mean we know most shows aren't hitting
their prime and like season seven i kind
of wish boardwalk had one more right
after but okay at least they know
they're ending right and and and
justified it knows its ending pan with
justified leaving and boardwalk leaving
all I got left is game with pearl I know
all the shows are leaving them I mean
there's other shows I like to but I mean
these are shows I love ya yeah this is
your and it's funny to seeing rail in
the season with what I always call the
characters that never show up the other
agents those we haven't seen I think we
saw the girl in the second episode I
think she was around but it's just it's
all about rail but it's nicely Natalie
say a little bit
it with the baby you know we know she's
doing the following right now Raylan's
ex-wife she's doing the following she's
never gonna be in the show full time as
long as the following also they want to
open up more romantic interest for Rayo
isn't him you got a lady smart Amy
smarts and this yeah yeah I got a new
fling I love that he's staying in this
the house you know from you know about a
guy just got arrested he also has
Mercedes driving around so it's good
it's definitely gonna be a good season
Oh another guest star for people who are
fans with a wire what's his name things
names wood Harris oh yeah who plays Avon
Barksdale he's in this as well as one of
the henchmen to that one marijuana
dealer right who knows Raylan's dad yeah
so I mean there's always great casting
so we're gonna have a few villains this
year I'm assuming the guys the Canadians
from Detroit I'm sure we'll hear from
Canada sorry from Windsor area though
I'm sure they'll come into play yeah
it's somehow we have the crows coming up
from florida to Kentucky you know that's
good i mean it's going to be it's gonna
be fun it's gonna be a fun season I
think and you know they're all gonna
somehow mixed together I love that one
scene when uh forgotten the name but
basically the marijuana dealer would ya
oh yeah to like meet up with where
Eiland and you get I don't think he
knows that Raelians a marshal yeah
really gives that speech is like look
I'm gonna drop is that my dad told me to
come pretend raap for if you can do this
if you want but some of your command
they're gonna die right now so he's like
I can kill four of you before you get
even you know break out your weapon who
look the other two I worry about Leia
he's like aunt and this thing right here
makes it all yeah it was really good i
mean it's i think we also have a new
player too with the lady the foreign
woman that um walton goggins character
gets involved with you know kind of
doesn't tell on him you know and now
she's she's gonna do you actually want
some money now she wants money 300,000
cuz he beat up her I'm Latvia I think
she was to go back home or something
like that Deborah her eyes I don't think
she wants to go home I think she just
wants the money yeah she wants the money
now so let's see and then you don't know
if that let some sort of romance he may
cheat on his jail Oh drama yeah love
triangle oh and also we ended the second
episode with his shipment of drugs being
hijacked yeah we don't know we saw like
the Michigan plates like but who we see
that the prostitute going up and talking
to one of Goggins guys talk about how
like hey you know the shipments coming
in you know there's like tomorrow so
like she knew like who did she tell ya
who you know who actually did all that
yeah I'm really liking how this season
is starting and and much more focused
yeah things listen to seemed all over
the place like this mystery who's this
guy what you have to do like in the past
of you know this town I'm like I really
care like I just one I just like the
characters I want to see the characters
just do interesting things that's the
season I kind of do like how they bring
back old characters you have Loretta
yeah we have from season two right yeah
season 2 which was actually my favorite
season and justified in it feels it
feels right because it feels like kind
of like regular life were sometimes you
see people a lot and then stadium for a
while come back into your life and
luckily and and I think you know I think
braylon feels responsible for Loretta
right yeah I mean and she's actually
playing everyone like I like at the end
he's just like look just go easy on us
next time I mean she's becoming I know
rocky the shirts I can go that far in
the future but she can become a boss
like you know I mean she could become
the next the lady from season two and
she's kind of had the screwed-up
childhood yeah not the best show she's
seen a lot of different stuff so who
knows but yeah I'm really liking how the
seasons going so far yeah I hope it just
keeps on the same path I hope so too
yeah I think it's gonna be great alright
so let us know what you guys think are
you guys watching justify what do you
think of this new season what do you
think of the fact that next season is
gonna be the last one you can post your
coma comments below on the website think
hero calm or on our YouTube channel
think you're Pro make sure to subscribe
to that though so much out with us on
Twitter lesson what you think let us
know what what are your favorite shows
of the cuz it's called you know winter /
spring season all these new shows coming
on what are your favorites how are you
liking justified you can tells us on
twitter at think hero i'm at griffin de
and we also have a Facebook page that
facebook.com slash think hero fans make
sure you like that page and you know
tweet out our videos post them on
Facebook it helps out
you